now that we've got the basics of order
of operations out of the way let's try
to tackle a really hairy and beastly
problem so here we have all sorts of
parentheses and numbers flying around
but in any of these order of operations
problems you really just have to take a
deep breath and remember we're going to
do parentheses first
parentheses p for parentheses then
exponents don't worry if you don't know
what exponents are because this has no
exponents in them then you're going to
do multiplication and division they're
at the same level then you do addition
and subtraction so some people remember
pemdas but if you remember pemdas
remember multiplication division same
level addition and subtraction also at
the same level so let's figure what the
order what order of operations say that
this should evaluate to so the first
thing we're going to do is our
parentheses and we have a lot of
parentheses here we have this
expression in parentheses right there
and then even within that we have these
parentheses
so our order of operations say look do
your parentheses first but in order to
evaluate this outer parenthesis this
orange thing we're going to have to
evaluate this thing in yellow right
there so let's evaluate this whole thing
so how can we simplify it well if we
look at just inside of it the first
thing we want to do is simplify the
parenthesis inside the parentheses
so you see this 5 minus 2 right there
we're going to do that first no matter
what and that's easy to evaluate 5 minus
2 is 3.
and so this simplifies to i'll do it
step by step once you get the hang of it
you can do multiple steps at once so
this is going to be 7
plus 3
times the 5 minus 2 which is 3 and then
you have and all of those have
parentheses around it and of course you
have all this stuff on either side the
divide for
no whoops that's not what i want i
wanted to copy and paste
i want to copy and paste that right
there so copy and then no that's giving
me the wrong thing
it would have been easier let me just
rewrite it that's the easiest thing i'm
having technical difficulties
so divided by 4
times 2 and on this side you had that 7
times 2 plus this thing in orange
parentheses there now at any step you
just look again we always want to do
parentheses first we keep wanting to do
this until there's really no parentheses
left so we have to evaluate this
parentheses in orange here so we have to
evaluate this thing first but in order
to evaluate this thing we have to look
inside of it and when you look inside of
it you have 7 plus 3 times 3. so if you
just had 7 plus 3 times 3 how would you
evaluate it we'll look back to your
order of operations we're inside the
parentheses here so inside of it they're
just they're no longer any parentheses
so the next thing we should do is there
are no exponents there is multiplication
so we do that before we do any addition
or subtraction so we want to do the
three times three before we add the
seven so this is going to be
seven
plus
and the three times three we wanna do
first we wanna do the multiplication
first seven plus 9
that's going to be in the orange
parentheses and then you have the 7
times 2 plus that on the left hand side
you have the divided by
4 times 2 on the right hand side and now
this the thing in parenthesis because we
still want to do the parentheses first
pretty easy to evaluate what's seven top
seven plus nine
seven plus nine is sixteen and so
everything we have simplifies to
seven times 2 plus 16
divided by 4
times 2.
now we don't have any parentheses left
so we don't have to worry about the p in
pemdas we have no e no exponents in this
so then we go straight to multiplication
and division we have a multiplication
we have some multiplication going on
there we have some division going on
here and a multiplication there so we
should do these next before we do this
addition right there so we could do this
multiplication
we could do that multiplication 7 times
2 is
14 we're going to wait to do that
addition we're going to wait to do that
addition and then here we have a 16
divided by 4 times 2. that gets priority
of the addition so we're going to do
that before we do the addition but how
do we evaluate that
do we do the division first we do the
multiplication first and remember i told
you in the last video when you have 2
when you have multiple operations of the
same level in this case division and
multiplication they're at the same level
you're safest going left to right or you
should go left to right so you do 16
divided by 4 is 4. so this thing right
here simplify 16 divided by 4 times 2 it
simplifies to
times 2
times 2. that's this thing in green
right there and then we're going to want
to do the multiplication next so this is
going to simplify 2 because your
multiplication takes priority over
addition this simplifies to 8 and so you
get 14 this 14 right here
plus
plus 8 and what's 14 plus eight that is
that is equal to 22
and we are done